est ce que tu aimes le plus est ce que
tu aimes le mont arafat alors va
commencer par exemple ce qu'on parle de
lui yves mourousi qu'est ce que tu aimes
le plus
et qu'est ce que tu aimes le moins chez
lui à le plus c'est premièrement folie
deuxièmement créativité troisièmement
la peau quatrièmement 1
parce que tel mais moi ce que jamais -
chez lui ouais
parfois les conseils avec deux des
conseils parfois c'est à dire quand je
pense que souvent on aime quelqu'un
parce qu'il est plus le temps avance
plus c'est pas des reproches mais plus
on est sceptique sur ce qu'il est
justement
donc si moi je déconne lundi n'est
sérieux ils trouvaient ça peut-être
génial au départ et maintenance ses
fonctions légèrement changé de
respectabilité précis ainsi ses
fonctions puisque ses fonctions est un
peu changé peut-être que votre connerie
à la limite - le déranger bon je suis
maman à des gens pour pas le mettre dans
l'eau dans la mer ceci dit je veux pas
changé non plus parce que j'aime chez
quelqu'un qui passait qui est passé du
terrain en direction ouest de questions
il a changé du quai les chefs et plus
animateur du journal télévisé de 13
heures
1 - avi
à mon avis
le petit point qui est douloureux reste
le fait qu'il ait moins
certainement moins libres 1 et qu'en
fait le privé n'est pas du tout un plus
en plus la liberté que le public on est
bien au contraire je prends le mec que
tu trouves le plus super et le mec que
tu trouves le plus nul ce super c
gainsbourg parce qu'il va jusqu'au bout
et en plus il est hyper pro et va
jusqu'au bout même faisait des critiques
s'en foutent man est le moins bien le
plus le plus nul 0 0 0
hervé claude hier à cause des moustaches
nom de quoi et moi ne bouge pas
l'impression vers nous très proche et
jean pierre pernaut un peu sorti mon
mémoire
donc non mais il ya des moments mais je
vais le plus grand moment de la vie
c'est plus beau monde ta vie l'apogée
tel jusqu'à maintenant bien sûr ce que
je te souhaite beaucoup d'autres mais
juste hama et à 17h10 ouais 20 juillet
1981 c'est son point à la clinique de la
médaille d'or avec le totalitarisme
pour le jeune homme
vivre à aucun prix peut-être un jour je
me lâche
alors maintenant quand il serait tu
préfères dans le sexe le truc que tu
préfères 1,5
salut tu peux me répondre les canaris ce
que je préfère mon sexe
[Musique]
sa position plaisir si tu réponds pas
tout de suite non c'est non si si c'est
le dire c'est arrivé c'est arrivé
est-ce qu'on soit fontaine en même temps
est-ce que tu déteste le plus simple il
vraiment te fait germer dans le sexe
paul dans le dos c'est un mec avec toi
que tu rencontres comme ça qui va des
poignards aucune chance
non ok n'a aucune chance j'ai envie de
les piller une fois présenté chez son
acteur préféré acteur préféré et vous en
allemand
kaba celui que des terres de hao fait
gelée qui déteste le plus
terminaux de choisir à mort ça nous
rappelle non pas la peine d'être peinard
au point que je trouve un mec il pète
est
c'est à dire cmh moderne
[Musique]
alors une attente comme alstom
c'est ce que j'espère compte pas sur moi
vilaine en 2000 elle ghislaine
l'habitation s'est pas mis lamain
génération bar ilan de bonjour donc
voilà c'est ça ouais c'est pas moi qui
ai je sais quoi bon le chanteur préfère
c'est gainsbourg attendus tout à l'heure
mais oui celui que tu supportes pas
julien disent de lui à la radio tu donne
un coup de pied dans le poste va bien
quand même
et
c'est toute la france rac pour lui
entraînez vous fera
l'intérêt des renault goldman seraient
déjà plus gênant mais non les super
moyens
tu préfères pires nouvelles d'alsace une
question intérim a bon dos tout de suite
je suis un canadien parce que le texte
est nettement plus intelligents chez qui
fera notre avant match
l'homme politique que tu détestes coûte
en fait une gaffe tu préfères comme ça
tout faire au moins un copain et même
politique vers la supporter la même
politique vraiment que tu essaies gerber
rech
c'est facile bon
vraiment qui me fait gerber theater pour
voir s'il est au pouvoir la peine tu
vois cela c'est tellement attendu sur
ses en face comme ça il est hyper lent
et la normale en celui qui préfère fait
vraiment un bot dans la ccara mitterrand
des cours est sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars d'études
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux